欢迎收听谷外,我是星梦宫
本集节目由EVOASIS赞助
EVOASIS是原点科技旗下的充电服务品牌
股票代号7922,最近刚登陆新贵
我自己是电动车主,也去他们的林口站充电体验很好
有时候你开车在外面,最怕的其实不是没电
是找不到合适的充电站
或是到了之后还要再排很久
EVOASIS给的感觉是站点够多,操作直觉
随时补电很方便
整体流程很顺,对电动车主来说稳定性非常重要
现在他们持续在全台扩展
已经是全台最大的充电网
提供快充慢充,家用充电
还有跨品牌充电慢油服务
意思就是说不管你是平常通勤,假日出游
甚至是临时跑远一点,只要是EVOASIS的会员
都比较容易找到地方补电
不用一直焦虑剩几趴
尤其现在电动车越来越多
充电这个事情跟加油一样变成日常的一部分
那这样站点密度高
充电速度跟整体的便利性
就会直接影响到用车体验
如果说本来就是电车
车主或是正在考虑入手电动车
可以去了解一下EVOASIS
想要看最新的站点
充电费率跟活动资讯
可以直接下载EVOASIS的APP来查看看
以上为品牌合作资讯
不构成任何投资建议
有任何需要的朋友们
都可以在我们资讯栏找到
更多关于EVOASIS的说明与连结
时间过得非常快
2026就这样要过掉一半了
我相信大家应该都跟我一样
是抱持着一个非常震惊的心态
就连我现在讲这一段话
我都觉得有点吓到
就时间也过得太快了吧
在上半年不知道大家过得怎么样
不管是你的生活上还是工作上
我这边就简单的去做一下
自己上半年的一些总结
在下一期节目的时候
就会进入到7月1号
也就是下半年的开始
跟第三季的开始
那时候我们就把它当成是一个新的开始
有时候去稍微的总结一下
就可以去wrap it up
就是大概在过去一阵子
你自己的表现
如果是好的话
那就提醒自己不要膨胀
接下来就有新的挑战
如果是不好的话
那就重新的去整理一下
自己的情况
然后接着还是要再去面对新的挑战
那我自己的上半年
我是觉得可能算是我人生的高光时刻
不管是在工作
或者说在自己的生活方面
我都是算是非常的喜欢
也非常的感恩上天
或者是不管是什么不可知的力量
或者说身边的家人朋友
跟工作上的同业
总之就是算是收获到了一个
非常好的上半年
应该是在历史上会留名的
不管是哪一个层面
那现在讲在生活的层面
就是我认为
减重这个决定是非常好的
同时在自己的体能的提升上
我觉得也形成了一种那种飞轮的效应
就最早只是想说
反正那时候有注意到说
医师有提醒我
你已经有一点点的高血压的前期
所以可能要稍微注意一下
自己的饮食或什么的
那后来就是在对话之中得知到
他跟我讲说
你大概就降一公斤
就可以降一毫米拱住
那我说那我当然就直接用减重的方式
去做处理
那本来心态其实有点类似说
反正针就先打下去
那接着呢
反正大概能够降一点重量
稍微能够过关角
就这种得过且过
那可是后来针打下去之后
因为意识到自己的食量
完全没有受到影响
那时候身边还有一些大哥朋友
会跟我分享说
那个针打下去
你甚至连运动都不想动
什么性欲会变很低之类的
你妈的完全都只想当一摊烂肉之类的
所以你要注意
你可能会掉很多的肌肉
那就没想到自己算是相对幸运的
就是打这个针
没有什么不良的副作用
然后整天还是跑去运动
因为这样子
去接触了像是网球
然后以及功能性
或者机能性训练
那这个对我的人生的改变是非常大
就是一个小小的决定
可是从此以后
我觉得我生活形态
觉得就此改变
因为我自己是非常喜欢
下的一个形态跟样貌
那所以在身体上面
我觉得是做得非常好
那在自己的家人孩子的方面
孩子的身体检查
各种状况也都已经是
慢慢的去把它排除掉了
那所以下就是一个健康的孩子
以前就会觉得说
会不会这边有问题
那边有一个问题
那就整天会想要去跑医院
或是去做更多的
不管是要去获得医嘱
或是你要获得second opinion
反正就整天去往医院跑
那在这个上半年
也算是相对的
去把它给解决掉了
那在工作方面呢
更是非常的顺利啦
那其实我相信
绝大多数有去参与股票市场的人
应该都比较难
表现得不好
那以我们的节目的气氛仔来讲
就绝大多数人
可能是去买0050这样子的东西嘛
那今年的year to date
都还是有个50%
这个是非常吓人的数字
那所以我相信
绝大多数人
在投资
或者说在这个
跟怎么讲
买卖相关的方面呢
应该都还蛮不错的
那至于是实体生意的话
可能就比较
一翻两瞪眼
有些人的生活
可能就没这么好
那因为我自己的工作
就是着重在投资方面嘛
所以对我来讲
我算是过了一个
非常好的上半年
那目前我的绩效的highlight
是落在差不多4到6月
那其实4到6月
也是大盘一个
高速爬升的时间啦
所以它一定有那种
beta加分的成分在里面
那只是5月的那一波呢
算是
我有史以来
第一次感受到
好像什么事情都不用做
然后就可以疯狂赚钱的
一段时间
因为那时候手上的持股
几乎都涨到进去储值股
然后最恐怖的是
就是过往的惯例啦
就进储值股之后
可能它的波动性就会降低
或者说它会变成
这个区间盘
那可是在差不多
4、5月的时候
有很多储值股
它反而是变成标股
所以就是越关越大尾
从5分钟变20分钟
然后甚至是连续储值
那那段时间呢
因为我绝大多数的部位
都是被锁在储值股里面
所以连动都不能动
那过往是这样子
就是可能一个东西
在那边喷喷喷
那有时候会出现一些回挡
有时候会去踩一些均线
可能我就会去调节
去减嘛
然后或甚至
我不一定是想把它卖掉
因为在过程之中
我可能一直注意到
新的题材嘛
那我要去买新的题材
我是习惯满仓的那一种人
所以我就必须要
卖东西去买
也就是说
我不是不看好它
我就是需要把它卖出来
因为我东西要花钱嘛
我又没有办法
从天上掉钱下来
那所以其实过往呢
去报一些波段
虽然理论上
在过去一阵子
已经是比之前更好
就是你已经
比较可以去吃到
那种大型的波段
可是在过程之中
你就一直慢慢去
做一些减码跟调节
那这当然又要有坏了
就是坏的部分
就是有时候你注意到
一些那种超级大鱼
你没有用全仓
去把它吃完
那好的部分
就是有时候
你减码的东西
它后来就证实
它真的只是一个小波段
然后就没有吃到
但绝大多数人的想法
应该都跟我是比较类似
如果可以稍微
轻松一点赚钱
谁不想要轻松一点赚钱
那也因为东西
会被灌在储值里面
是完全是动弹不得
那甚至那时候
有些自己手上的部位是
它进储值的时候
你大概只要丢个
可能30张50张
它本来量还蛮大的
可是它进储值之后
30张50张
你可能就可以
直接把它灌到碟亭
所以你根本就是
完全不可能去动它
然后它就这样一直上去
上到储值后
才有办法给你去做调节
那所以自己的五月
就算是打出一个
非常暴利的报酬
那自己回头看会觉得
那时候四月
已经觉得非常不可思议了
然后没有想到到五月
还有这样子一波
所以真的只有
感恩赞叹的心情
那今年年初到现在
也算是切了蛮多的题材
一开始是做卫星相关
那后来有切一些载板
那再来做一些
玻璃机板的东西
这都差不多在第一季
左右的时候就完成了
也就是后来
我就差不多去减码
再换到新的东西
那进入到第二季
就开始去做一些
涨价的题材
像是被动元件
或者说比较近期的
功率元件等等
那在美股这边
动作就比较少一点
因为一般来说
都是用较为长期的心态
去看它
那最近一个
比较大的调动就是
因为需要去挪钱出来
买SpaceX
那所以就会把一些
手上持股
可能表现比较不好的
就把它卖一卖
然后以及Tesla
也卖一卖
因为觉得反正我最主要
要去买Tesla
也是为了压住马斯克
那现在有一个SpaceX
可以压住
那所以就去挑截出
一部分的资金
去买了SpaceX
那再来比较大的亮点
就是算是有压到
整个CPU
然后再来ASIC的话
Marvell也是有压到
但是最近这几档
都稍微都有去
做一点调节
为什么
因为可以注意到
美股的走势
蛮分化的
那一般在台股这边
就是可能转弱的东西
我就会把它卖掉
那可是美股
转弱的东西
我还蛮喜欢去接刀的
所以就是看到
可能像是
一些掉下来的科学巨头
他们现在可能
落到一个
我觉得蛮不错的价位
或是一些蛮大的均线
那所以就有去把一些
相对强势的东西
砍一点出来
然后再换到这些
比较弱的东西
那再来就是在
软铁的持股
也有去做一些调整
其实我自己本来心中
是觉得像Planetier
这种估值超高的东西
要有机会继续往前冲
就是一般这种
大家最不相信
觉得贵到不可思议
那甚至很多人
想上去放空的东西
它就会持续的领头下去
但看起来
在过去一阵子
它的表现是相对的
比较疲弱一点
那在整个Portfolio里面
走得比较好的
像是Cross Strike
那好的东西
就持续有在去点它
那比较没有那么好的东西
也是不会到
要需要去减
但是就不会再去
做额外的一个加码
是目前用这样的态度去看
那自己心中的一个剧本
是认为说
在美股这边
是相对的难做一点
那我还是相信
后面一定是要
转进去应用层面的
一些表现
所以像是巨头
应该要有一些机会
那特别我比较喜欢的
会是Google
因为Google它现在
在降本增效方面
算是做得非常好
不管是自己的晶片开发
或是一些Portfolio的配置
在模型的各种应用层面上
其实我觉得
它把公司调整到
一个蛮好的状态
那所以目前
虽然科技巨头表现
是没有这么好
但我还是会觉得
可能可以往这边
去做一个压住
那苹果的话
是我相信在Age短之后
它有机会会是一个
持续维持领导地位的公司
虽然可能在过去一阵子
大家比较不喜欢它
认为说它在AI
没有布局或什么的
但是像我们自己
满手都还是苹果的产品
所以就还是会相信说
这家公司是有机会
会为我们带来一些惊喜
那只是一直没有找到
比较合适的切入点
我自己会觉得说
可能等到它稍微转强一点
像礼拜五有注意到
已经跌深的
像微软或是说苹果
它们反而是在
大家很不好的时候
它们就跳起来
那如果说在接下来
你注意到它们持续上去的话
那我觉得我可能会
把一些钱移到这些地方来
所以以美股来说
它的表现是跟台股比起来
我觉得差蛮多的
那还是相信说
后面是有机会
因为一般台股跟美股市场
特别是我们节目
也这么多年的
那过去我们的经验
就是会轮来轮去
有时候大家在那边
狂骂美股很烂的时候
后来美股就给你惊喜
那反之一统
大家觉得台股不好的时候
后来台股有时候
就会给你一些惊喜
那所以就还是持续的去做
该有的一些布局
那整个上半年
目前看下来是非常的满意
虽然在过去的一个礼拜
算是遭受到了
蛮大的一个重击
按照我自己的
进职的表现来说
差不多再这样下去的话
很快就会把
六月的东西给赔掉
那四五月要赔掉
就老实讲
应该是还蛮困难的
因为已经直接
再拉出一个档次了
所以按我的看法
会认为说
特别是有蛮多的部位
其实都已经是处于一个
相对低成本
当然相对低成本
不代表说
它一直跌
你就不用去处分它
不用去动它
但一般来讲
你真的会比较有耐心
你会比较可以
怎么样
在卡到好的位置的
一个状况之下
有机会吃到更大的一个破段
位置没有卡好
就像说你住在一个
破段的短线高点
很多时候它往下跌的时候
你就会觉得受不了
你就想把它砍掉
那所以就会觉得说
反正且战且走
慢慢的观察下去
那也希望大家
在接下来的下半年
也可以表现的蛮不错
虽然我自己
目前的态度
会比较偏向是中性
我还是觉得说
今年会是一个多头年
但是因为上半年
真的他妈太夸张了
你很难去想象
后面还可以更夸张
但我相信我四月
一定也讲过类似的话
就是四月好的不可思议
很难想象
后面可以更好
结果后来有一个
更好的五月
那六月一开始
也都非常好
但是在六月的下半之后
就开始有一点
那种业力引爆的感觉
所以整体来说是这样
那也希望大家
在接下来的半年
可以弄出一个
令你满意的半年
不管它是
可能在工作
在家庭或是事业上
不管你要专注的
东西是什么
还是投资
希望大家都可以去
达成自己要的一个目标
大概这样子
好那接下来
我们就来回归一下
最近的盘面
稍微讲一下
自己的一个看法
那老实说呢
我自己本身是以为
大概在礼拜三
礼拜四左右
就会开始看到
盘面出现一些反弹
特别是其实在礼拜四的
差不多过了
11点半12点之后
你就注意到说
台股有很多中小型
其实它是在拉尾盘
然后一些过去的强势股
也都在拉尾盘
所以本来
我以为差不多
到这个地方就结束
然后我就已经有
持续的把钱打进去
然后在礼拜五的时候
早上是先杀
然后杀完之后
到中午的时候
有一些相对强势的股票
有试着站回去
我就被套在一个
他妈日内的高点
因为我就觉得说
这个地方应该
就是要反攻了
因为前面
特别是在9点多
还10点的时候
有看到国巨的期货
直接跑去跌停
这什么意思
就它的现股
根本就还没有要去跌停
可是期货先跌停
一定是那一堆
杠杆杠超大的
要自杀了
所以就会认为说
有可能筹码到这边
已经洗了差不多了
然后在外加的时候
有注意到说
台资有一段
突然间的急杀
那个我认为也是一些
就是杠杆杠到最大的人
他们可能出现了一些
必须要自断
或甚至是已经
要看到断头的压力
所以赶快把东西
给处分掉
那就是说恐慌大逃杀
看到这个东西
就会觉得说
那我接下来就是等到
有东西开始
要站回去的时候
我就要再把部位打进去
但我现在心中的感受是
我觉得好像
有一点打得太快
也就是说
如果那时候反弹
真的是出在礼拜四的话
我会觉得说
整体的形态
是涨得还蛮有机会
就是在接下来
很快又会再跑下去新高
那可是因为
在额外多了一个礼拜五
然后这一根算是蛮大的
然后你就注意到说
其实过往的一些
热门族群的股票
他们在礼拜五的时候
有蛮多是直接
跑到季线下面去了
那按照我们自己的经验
就是这些跑到
季线下面的东西
当然你说反弹
会不会看到
反弹是会看到
因为杀很快的东西
就是后面会出一些反弹
那可是呢
就是一般如果说
你一次就跌到
季线以下的话呢
就是蛮高几率
因为他可能后面扣底
就会转成是负的嘛
那所以在反弹的过程之中
摸到一些
可能比较大的群线
你就会注意到
一堆那种美红干的
就会开始
因为他解套了
所以就赶快把东西丢掉
所以就会导致说
他后来要上去的一个几率
或者说他要上去的力道
都会变得蛮小的
那也就是说
在我的角度会认为说
如果他本来在礼拜三
礼拜四就继续上去的话
其实市场的广度
都还蛮大的
可是因为
有蛮多东西就直接摔破了
所以市场的广度就变小了
就可能会集中在一些
真的还蛮强势的东西
有机会会
后面又再跑上去
可是呢
就是那些只要去杀太深的
一般可能就是在反弹之后
你就会注意到
他会再一次的软掉
所以呢
这边可能是要稍微
比较小心的点了啦
就是说如果你手上的部位
是有看到说
他直接一路往下灌
然后灌爆季线的
但我是认为说
就是有时候比较太急
就是在那种最恐慌的时候
把部位砍掉
因为很多时候你回头看
就会发现你砍在最低点
可是一般这种
真的回到超级深
然后已经跑到
你就想嘛
就季线就是60天平均成本啦
也就是说过去60天
买人全部都套牢了嘛
那这些东西在反弹之后呢
就是有机会会有蛮大的卖压
也就是说他可能也不一定上得去
他只是让你少赔一点
或者说
让你可能未实现的获利
再多跑回来一点点
但是后面要再继续的快速进攻
一般来说
几率是偏低
所以就是说
多了这一两根下去
我会觉得
有些东西可能就开始走位啦
当然这个可能是直接
分析给一些人听
因为对我来讲
我目前手上的东西
都还是属于那种
比较强势的东西
反正就是那些涨价元件嘛
那他们基本上都离
季线在蛮远的
可是我注意到
就是过去的一些热门族群
他们是直接跑到季线下面去了
那这个就是大家自己
要稍微注意一下
因为一般跑到季线下面的东西
市场上的做多意愿
觉得偏低啊
除非他突然间有一个
就是前面大家都没有听过的
好消息丢出来
不然这就是我们讲的
做坏掉了
就被丢坏掉了
他后面要再爬回去
就会是相对的困难一点
那在过去一阵子
当然大家就开始讨论说
这一波的修正
到底在跌什么
他当然有可能是跟
就是差不多6月5号
就我生日那附近的时候
不是也是一个超大的沙盘吗
跌蛮深的
然后后来就高速的拉回来
在6月15号左右
就开始一路在往上喷了嘛
当然也有可能是像
这样子的一个状态啦
但就是说
因为一般在市场下跌的时候
你就会知道
有很多的坏消息丢出来
那有些可能就是比较夸张一点
有些就是比较唬烂一点
但反正只要盘不好
就一定有一些坏消息
那一般我们不会太在意
那些乱丢出来的坏消息
可是有一些可能比较关键的
我们会稍微的看一下
那据说像最近有一个说法
就是说现在可能是一些
主权基金啊
退休金
因为他们在过去的一季
表现非常好
就跟你各位
或是跟我一样
大家可能都在科技股
赚到蛮多钱的
那他们就必须要去执行
就是每个季度的一个rebalance
这什么意思呢
就他portfolio里面
可能有东西是喷了30%
那有东西呢
可能是往下跌的
有东西可能是在横盘
那相对来说
那些涨比较多的
是不是就是在他的
净值的占比会变高
那因为他们是走一个
比较保守的策略
所以呢
他们就会选择去把这些
变高变贵的东西
去做一个
比较那种机械式的减嘛
那减嘛出来的钱呢
就会去买那些
现在可能已经是跑到
他在净值里面
百分比是比较低的东西
去做一些加嘛
那这个我们把它称为
是一个rebalance
那我觉得是
蛮合理的一个说法
就是因为可能在过去
科技股真的涨很多
所以导致就是你注意到说
有蛮多
喷很多的东西
然后被大量的提款
这个可能就是一种
就是市场那些大资金
太弱流强的一个结果
那当然也有些人说
是因为美伊战争这边
又什么再一次去轰人家
那我稍微的看了一下
其实现在有蛮多
所谓的革命卫队
在做什么事情的新闻
那个都偏向是假消息
就是你真的去认真查之后
就会知道说
他的假消息
或者说他其实没有一些
外电的来源之类的
那就算是有外电的来源
可能是一些那种
野鸡报道之类的
那我觉得这一点
其实非常简单去做判断
就直接看油价就好
就油价已经
跌到七八十块左右
所以就像那时候
跟大家分享
因为那时候QA
有一个听众问我说
战争怎么看
我就说其实基本上
当你注意到说
他在丢一些东西
然后市场都已经
没有反应的时候
我们会去相信
市场的一个判断
那当你已经注意到说
油价已经掉到这个位置
其实应该就已经
在一个善后的阶段
就是说过去的
那个Face已经结束了
当然我们不排除
就是川普我们可能
再搞一个新的Face出来
那是有机会
只是就是
美伊战争这个事情
应该不会是市场这一波
驱动它掉下去的一个主因
因为你直接看油价
就已经是
像是Open Book一样了
那再来有些人讲说
会不会是升息的可能性
升息的可能性
当然你要看
联总会看的东西是什么
那有些人讲说
他最主要是锁定核心CPI
这是一个比较主流的说法
那有些人讲说
他其实会看整体
外面的环境是怎么样
也会去做一些调动
那像油价可能很高的时候
大家就会担心
油价现在是相对低下来
可能就还好
可是大家同时也注意到说
因为AI导致
像大家看到
那个美光的财报超级好
那现在看到
苹果也受不了要涨价了
所以有没有可能
要去压制这些
所谓的通膨的状态
即便大老板本人
川普是说
他喜欢通膨没有问题
然后去做什么
很大幅度的升息
什么一年内
要赶快再多拉个
什么三次以上之类
这个我觉得
也是属于几率偏低
因为第一个
就大老板本身
他应该是
不会想要这样的事情发生
然后再来
第二个是
其实现在的这些价格
我们看到很多那种
涨价狂潮什么
他其实比较集中在
像是Data Center这边
因为这些大型的客户
对他来讲
像以下一个AI Server来说
他可能在
记忆体这边的Bomb Cost
就已经是跑30%去了
他成本有30%的记忆体
可是他们还是买得很高兴
因为对这些巨头来讲
他们太有钱了
那反映在消费端这边的话
可能就是有一些需求
被破坏掉
也就是说
当价格涨到某个位置
这电脑还可以用
GTA是可能
11月才出
10月才出
我现在不用急着换电脑
所以大家会选择
去遞延自己的消费
然后外加其实过去的盘面很好
大家都想要把钱
全部打进市场里面
所以我会觉得说
他比较不会是那种
就是可能超大范围的
你会注意到这种涨价
影响到大家的生活
反而是可能
他是集中在一些小范围内
当然不排除后面
会把它扩散出来
然后特别是这一波的财富效应
让很多人在股票市场赚到钱
一般我们一个说法是这样子
就是
当财富效应正在发生扩张的时候
也就是可能盘面狂涨的时候
大家会想说
理论上不是每个人都变有钱了吗
特别像美国
几乎大家都上车
因为他们有401K什么的
所以应该你变有钱
你就想多花钱
可是其实不一定是这样子
因为在盘很好的时候
大家会认为说
我现在不把钱丢进去市场里面的话
我的机会成本太高了
所以大家都会持续往市场里面丢
那会等到什么时候
就等到说可能盘面开始震荡
开始会修理人
修理人的频率开始变得很高
或者说开始
也会有很多的
那种袋鼠盘的现象产生的时候
然后大家会产生一个想法
像我最近就开始产生这种想法
马的赔掉不如花掉
那这时候可能就会去
把一些股票的资产拉出来
然后可能去买别的东西
所以我觉得说
可能一些消费是在那个时候才会发生
所以等到那个时候
我们再来观察说
现在这些涨价
到底会不会去
非常大幅度的冲击消费
它会比较准一点点
就是需求到底会不会破坏掉
那时候看会相对的准一点点
那不然说像台湾的一些房地产市场
我觉得也是
因为过去很多炒房的资金
现在也都丢进去股票市场里面
你应该都在报道上面看到什么
世代同堂力都有的没有的
每个人都在借钱
对那可能就是要等到市场
稍微告一个段落之后
你就会注意到说这些钱
有些我自己猜测
它就会回溜回去房地产
或者跑去买其他的东西
那应该是后面会有机会看到的一个情形
反正总之会认为说
它没有太大的一个压力
需要在短期内去做一个急迫的升息
我就觉得这个应该也不是
最主要的一个核心的理由
所以纵观下来
我觉得不是战争
说什么快速升息
我觉得应该rebalance那个
就你硬要去找一个理由的话
这个东西是比较接近的
至于市场上其他人讲的
那什么AI泡沫什么的
这个你就听听就好
因为那些AI泡沫论者
从2023、2024一路讲到现在
他总会有对的一天
你懂吗
他总会有一天被他讲中
可是他错过的是这么大段的一个东西
所以我觉得那个就稍微看看就好
但我最近确实是有跟自己的身边朋友
讨论到一件事情
就是这些科技巨头的股东
会不会开始有一些坐不住了
为什么
因为你看到说
像美光的毛利率80几
他搞不好在接下来几个Q
甚至会上到90几
就是暴利
他现在是随便卖随便赚
那这些科技巨头
他们是付钱的支出方
他们也是去做出应用
然后真的去实践
AI导入大家的生活中
去改变大家生活的那一方
可是他们的股价的表现非常不好
他们的cash flow
有些可能甚至要跑到负值去了
所以在这样的一个状况之下
是不是就是会开始有一些检讨的声音出现
这个是有机会
虽然可能在DeepSeek那一波
就有类似在市场上
有这样的一个状况
这样子一个讨论
那后面因为DeepSeek
他并没有烧得很大
他是造成一些改变
没错
就是大家把一些注意力
可能发到开源模型去
可是那时候并没有造成这么大的一个讨论
那看这波有没有机会
去酝酿出这样的一个讨论
就是这些巨头的股东
会不会开始住不住
然后觉得说
这些钱都付给这些零组件厂商
被他赚走了
我们全部买的这么急
可是成效不一定有看到
那我们是不是还是要推的这么快
就后面去注意一下
有没有这样的论述跑出来的可能性
我觉得可能盘面再继续转差的时候
就会有这样子论述跑出来的可能性
那到时候再来看
会不会对市场的Sentiment
造成一些影响
那目前我们看下来会觉得
特别是我最近有少了一些
这些巨头们
他们去Deploy AI伺服器的数字
他们在台系供应链的拉货
目前看起来
还是没有什么太多的问题
那当然至于是不是要去杀估值什么
这个我就没有办法去做太多判断
可是纯就产业层面来看
其实有蛮多事情都还在酝酿中
所以我觉得
比较像是一个市场信心
短期内的丢失
就跟过去几波的一些修正
可能是比较类似
像是2026年的3月的那一波
也是正当的修
然后再来就是可能6月初的那一波
我觉得现在是比较偏向这样的一个情形
但是因为真的已经有一些东西开始出现
它是跑到季线下面去的
所以还是要自己稍微的注意一下
因为你可能去看到大盘的位置
还是蛮不错的
还是有机会踩到大军线继续进攻
可是你自己手上不会
如果开始发现说
它站不回去的话
这个要稍微的注意一下
即便它可能是
AI相关的东西
即便它可能是市场上一些大体裁
但资金没有在这边
它就是可能会比较难上去
也就是说你可能掉季线的部分
是一个以价值投资来讲
相对好的买点
但你就有机会要等
有机会要等
这个可能是稍微要看一下的
好 接下来我们来稍微的聊一下
苹果的涨价话题
苹果终于是撑不住了
也在机器的价格高涨的状况之下
拿他们去上修了
我们也就是看到说
像是MacBook
或是一些产品线的价格
拉了大概十几到二十%左右的一个位置
那在这个时间涨价还蛮有趣的
就本来可能大家想象会
它跟着一些新品去做涨价
可能是还OK
但它选择在这个时间
某个程度上去涨了一些
像是可以把它称为是旧品的东西
那是不是代表说
它在新品的涨价
也先去做了一个预热
就这个东西后面丢出来
也会是一个
就是可能会让一些人吓到的价格
但是让一些人吓到的价格
不代表会让果粉吓到
这个非常重要
所以有时候在市场里面
去讨论一些话题的时候
我觉得首先你要先定义出
你的客人是谁
然后再来就是
讨论的时候你要知道
对方是不是跟你是同一类型的人
就是我们有时候会知道说
反正河水不犯井水
大家其实是在不同圈子的东西
有些人去买苹果的
他们把它称为是臭盘子
那这些臭盘子
其实他一辈子也不会跑去买安卓
那安卓的一辈子
可能也不会跑去买苹果
所以你们在那边互干了半天
其实大家是彼此不影响对方
只有在一些特殊的场域上
像在游戏业界
很常会因为外面的一些DI的言论
然后去改变游戏的设计
可是他们最终也开始发现说
其实很多在对这些游戏的
所谓的多元价值去做批评的人
他们本身不太会买游戏
蛮多游戏商注意到这件事情了
所以他们知道说
他真的要去巩固的
其实是他的客人
而不是那一些
可能就是在场外含烧的人
所以一样的道理
你说苹果这个涨价数字高不高
以我自己身为果粉的角度来说
我觉得一定是高的
但你说会不会继续买
就还是会买
听到这边
你不是果粉
就是说妈的你这个臭盘子
可是果粉的听到这边就觉得说
啊
那不就是这样子
那其实老实讲
你说这个记忆体的markup价格
苹果他确实是
在记忆体这边呢
是做了蛮多的涨价了
就是说他不可能的
很老实去反映他原物料的价格
我随便举例
假设记忆体
他多差一条
那成本假设是10块好了
从10块变20块的成本
他不可能
他就是在售价上面加你10块
因为他有他的毛利要顾
然后再来就是说
也有品牌价值这一点
然后这点可能就是说
一样我刚才前面讲的
井水不犯河水
不懂的人就是永远不会懂
啊懂的人
其实也不需要去做太多的说明
但我们这边还是稍微说明一下
简单来讲就是说
一个爱马仕的包包
他在上面去多给你几个毛钉
或是什么多缝个几块皮革
他可以多卖你几千上万
那可是如果你今天是一个
不知道华强北那边
假设有在弄包包的话
那这个包包
你额外再打一个毛钉
他可能就是成本价
然后再额外加一点点
就这样就给你
那可是你会说
所以买华强北的包包
就比爱马仕
划算吗
OK对
这是可能是一个
比较极端的举例
那一样见仁见智
以他手机的角度来讲
我还是不会去买
可能就是中细手机之类的
我就是会买苹果
那可是以包包角度来讲
我还真的可能会去买
那个华强北的包包
所以一样的道理就是
这个东西
它是比较属于一个
见仁见智的东西
所以你在网上看到很多吵架
他们其实是一个
就是大家互相在倾谈
你们吵了半天
其实你们彼此的生活
都还是会去走各自的路
你觉得对方是白痴
对方刚好也觉得你是白痴
那可是呢
要注意的点是
这个东西会不会真的影响到
实际上会买这个产品的人
这个才是可能在
各种话题里面
要讨论的一个重点
那其实这种东西呢
也不用去做太多网络的辩驳
最后面直接看销量就好
就类似说
我们去做股票上的投资
你不用去讨论太多
那种战争的话题
大概知道就好
最后面直接看油价就好
因为那就是一个结果嘛
那一样的道理
如果我们今天注意到
销量的数字是跑得不好的话
那就反映了
它这个价格可能就是
不被它本来的消费者接受
然后再来就是
可能新的想加入的消费者
也会因为这样子会却步
所以才反映到你的销量是不好
那时候可能就等到
用销量去做一个佐证就最好了
所以像前阵子不是蛮多人
也是整天在凑苹果说什么
你跟不到AI时代
你表现不好吗
可是呢太香了
因为那时候以各家其他手机OEM
他们为了要去反映记忆体的涨价
严格上来说不是说什么
他们先涨价
他们是比较黑心的
应该是说苹果的价格年性
一般来说都是比较高
它提早就已经在上面
它毛利是比较肥
所以它不用这么快去反映
那些中系的OEM
或是一些什么韩系
或说美系的手机
可能没有办法
它没有这么大的一个护城额
它立刻去做反映
所以在当下的一个相对之下
大家觉得苹果是相对划算的
所以导致说苹果那时候
冲一波销量出来
可是苹果如果现在
它也跟进了这个涨价
那我们就要去看后续的一个
这个销量的表现是怎么样
然后再来判断说
这个涨价到底消费者
吃不吃得下去
有时候你觉得吃不下去
可能只是你不是它的受众
所以这个可能要理性一点
去看会比较准一点
但一般来说
我们看到这种涨价的东西
会是报一个比较正向的讯号
不然说像是供应链的这边涨价
除非说你看到这个涨价
是客户已经拒绝去吃了
你才会去担心
那以目前在AI端来说
我觉得蛮多做供应链的
其实我们的胃口也被养坏掉了
就会觉得说这些涨价
怎么看到那种波纤布
或是你看到什么Q布
然后或者是各式各样的原物料
零组件 被动元件 记忆体
你知道你怎么涨
这些亏巨头都会买单吗
所以大家已经是
丧失了那种风险意识
反正怎么涨他们都会买单
只要是涨价就等于是好消息
那消费端这边
其实是要比较小心一点的
因为它最终要面对的是普罗百姓
那普罗百姓不是他妈的
每个都有在做股票炒房地产
或者说他盛观发财赚很多钱
有蛮多可能是
他就是拿一个差不多的薪水
所以一个东西贵了20%
贵了30%
它不像那些亏巨头
反正无条件接受
我就知道去参与AI竞赛
我一定会买
那消费者可能有些就
真的就不买了
所以他就会直接很血淋淋的
反映在他的销量上面
所以这可能也解释了
就是为什么你看到一些
供应链的股票
你听到涨价
基本上就等于说
一定会往上涨
可是为什么苹果的涨价
刚出来是一件碟
当然它隔一天又继续涨
所以这个还比较
我觉得neutral
你还没有办法下去做判断
还是要观察一下
因为其实我觉得
大家应该都很想问这个问题
就是现在终端消费市场
到底有没有利器
那现在比较难判断的主因
是因为过去的股票涨很多
大家理论上都相信
财富效应会蔓延出来
会买各种东西
可是因为就是股票一直在涨
所以大家不愿意出来
那出来之后
说不定你还会看到
一个消费的龙井
这个是有机会看到的
所以到时候那些涨价
不一定会对这些消费者
造成一些压力
这是有机会的
所以这个我们还是得
稍微的看一下
才可以去做一个
比较全面的判断
所以就大概评论一下这件事情
那快速的总结一下
其实去做Markup这件事情
它并不是苹果的一个专利
只是苹果它一般就是可能
毛利看起来特别厚
然后它的价格是特别廉
这是真的
可是其他人
其实也都会去做类似的事情
唯一一个比较老实
在反映价格是什么
是中细的OEM
可是中细的OEM
为什么会老实反映价格
因为他们就是用低价廉价
去做强势战略的动作
所以他当然会用一个
可能相对便宜的价格
Markup比较少的价格
去对市场做贩售
可是你会去买那个
就是可能经济真的不好
开始出现一些消费降级
像之前在中国这边
是看到说他们那种
整形机卖的特别好
就是可能经济比较差的时候
才会有大家往那个方向去挤的
一个样态
可是如果经济好的时候
其实蛮多人都是
很乐意去吃那个Markup
所以我们要看一下说
就是这一波记忆体
造成的一个影响
那它目前看起来
我觉得对记忆体厂商来说
压力不会太大
因为只要这些巨头
持续买单的话
消费性不好
你看美光直接把消费性放掉
它根本就没差了
可是如果说
怎么说
就是在消费性这边
你开始注意到一些收手
因为这些人
你要知道
其实在科技巨头上班的这些人
或者是说
炒股票赚钱这些人
他们最终
他们其实也都是消费者
那如果说外面的世界
开始产生一些影响
价格开始高涨
然后导致
大家不愿意去做一些支出的话
其实最终都会影响到
就是最核心的那些
甚至是跟AI有关的需求
只是这个现在要讲
我觉得是有点太早
但趁着播
反正现在外面也都是鬼故事
就一次把所有的鬼故事讨论完
我觉得大家就之后会
可以去感受到
之前跟大家分享的
为什么我会说
有时候在修正的时候
那个故事你知道就好
可是你不要太认真去看待它
因为你会发现
每一次
就是以过去来讲
其实波段往下跌
5到8%的那个
机会是蛮多的吧
以大盘的角度来讲
每次跌的时候
那些鬼故事
你在之后新高的时候
你回头看
其实真的就没有半个人在讨论
所以它有点像是说
反正不好的时候
会被拿出来当一个谈资
但我们简单的去做一个review
那目前对于产业的角度
还是跟过去一样
就是我们没有注意到
有太多
显著的
立刻会反转的一个可能性
但是呢
确实是可能因为
一些资金面的驱动
导致加盘面出现
一些不一样的状况
那些rebalance
可能会trigger一些事情
那一些股票
可能跌到季限以下的
可能开始假设
因为我们现在不知道说
台面下的这些贷款
到底大家跌了多高
我们只知道很高
可是我们不知道跌在哪里
我们不知道他们
什么时候会开始
感受到压力要丢
会不会触发一个连锁反应
这个还是要
稍微小心一点
那比较容易去
保护自己的方式就是
你去稍微注意一下形态
那个均线如果开始拉平
开始做一个头的
虽然这边讲起来
会有点有些人会觉得说
这个感觉像是现先的
可是我们真的会参考这些东西
就是价格的一些变化
其实还是蛮重要的
你不可以完全说
我就是fundamental
然后一个东西一直爆爆爆
因为很多时候
那个价格变化会跑在前面
然后类似说
大家还记不记得那时候
在去年
关税帝军要开始出权的时候
那时候三月不是
美股整天在往下跌
就整天跌
然后没有消息
然后跌到后来
我那时候的说法是说
就是我要找一个
还OK的反弹
我要有尊严的出去
那后来就是有去做一些调整
然后于是我们后面看到
这个关税帝军的事情
所以当一个下跌
假设它持续的蔓延
持续的发生的话
有时候消息
它其实是跟在后面的
这个可能大家自己也是要
稍微的注意一下
所以大概这样
但以现阶段来说
我相信九道读书人
他就是一个获利回吐的问题而已
只是说吐到什么时候
大家会受不了
然后开始去乱卖
这我们不知道
但一般来讲
如果他不小心的回到太深
接着反弹又弹不上去的话
就会有乱卖的一个情形
这可能自己要稍微注意一下
就自己的现金水位
你有东西要买的
要稍微先腾点钱出来
大概这样
好 接下来我们来进入QA的部分
因为在QA这边
我们平常是礼拜三走Spotify
然后礼拜六走Apple
可是像我刚刚限动发的
就是现在Apple的
它的QA不知道为什么
都没有再更新了
所以在未来的一阵子
我们都先三六都维持在Spotify这边
我们先尽量都在Spotify这边
如果后面有一些变动
再跟大家说
大概这样子
好像没有
就是你要么就停下来帮忙
要么就是你就离开
然后可能打个电话
可是就算你不打电话
应该也是很多人会打电话
因为他就是在路中间
所以就是二选一
我自己的话
会怎么样做呢
一般来讲
我应该是会停下来的那一个
但如果我今天车上
假设有载我小孩
又在高速公路的话
我应该是会绕开
然后再报警
所以我觉得你也不用对自己
可能给太大的压力
说好像你很冷漠的绕开
不是啊
就是说你可能
你也没注意到
或者你当下没有反应过来
那个不是你的错
不要再想太多了
下面一位
Tim MK哥您好
小弟最近工作刚满五年
现在在MTK过得不是很开心
想换工作
但是又有点不晓得
要追求钱还是自由
您的话肯定是选钱吧
不过您28岁的时候
也是一样吗
爱您
PS即使发哥
前阵子涨停了超多根
但是因为公司的制度
周遭的人
跟我大多数在三月就卖了
这个听起来是一个
非常令人难受的故事
刚刚前面讲到MTK
我被人家笑出来的原因
不是因为我想要嘲笑
因为我身边真的蛮多朋友在MTK
我跟MTK也有一点渊源
就是去他们公司也参访过
然后也有去那边演讲过
所以算是认识了蛮多那边的人
我是感觉他们看起来
都还蛮快乐的
虽然我讲这个的时候
我相信他们很多心中
一定是有一些OS要讲
大M铲鼠条
快乐铲鼠条
快乐赚钱
那以一个
怎么讲
年轻人的角度来讲
我会认为说
赚钱是比较重要的
就是我也很难去想象说
工作本身是会非常快乐的
只要这个工作本身
它不会让我觉得心理压力很大
每天看到老板
我就想他妈给他一个走急
或者说每天想到上班
我就很忧郁的话
那我会认为说
反正上班本身
我这样问一个话
谁是没事去上班的
你各位
除非说你是五六十岁
然后第二春在家
真的不知道干嘛
才跑去
绝大多数你上班
你不就是为了去赚点钱吗
所以钱很多的话
稍微的有点不快乐
我觉得也是OK的
就是它应该是一个
可以接受的trade off
没有问题
所以在我的角度会觉得
如果你今天钱不够多的话
MTK是很多人
梦寐以求可以去的地方
甚至MTK在这几年
它
算是某种程度上的跳板吧
对不对
蛮多跳去的
你知道那几家
就跳到人家都觉得说
靠北整天挖我的人
那你要想
你没有这个经验
你也很难跳到
那几个公司去
我们就不要去点名了
但反正总之
它是一个应该
蛮多人称羡的地方
那这个东西
我觉得通常在各种工作室
你去问医生
医生家每个人都在跟你干说
他们的工作压力大
然后钱少
可是你在绝大多数人眼中
是你们就是台湾最有钱的人
就以领薪水来讲
很多时候你觉得
你自己没有钱
是因为你去比较的对象
是资产阶级
资产阶级是另外一回事
那个是长年的累积
或者说有时候要有一点
那种时事的背景在
要有一点胆识或怎么样的
薪水就是反而不败
你怎么样都可以拿到钱
所以我觉得MTK
已经是一个
大家都很羡慕的地方
除非你真的是极度的难受
那你去退而求其次
找一个薪水没这么高
但至少你心情好一点的地方去
也好
但我要跟你讲一个
很现实的东西是
你会以为说
你去别的地方会很好
说不定你跑到别的地方
是
你一样有不满的东西
然后钱又没有给够
所以那个不爽指数
反而会跑到更高
这个是有机会是这样子
要稍微注意一下
下面一位
Mark
梦宫老公安
刚从韩国打工度假回来
不知道要找什么工作
救命
不过珍味食堂真的好好吃
可惜Lisa现在不来韩国了
好想见到老公全家人
许愿可以找到一个
躺平的工作
爱您
不知道
现在有什么工作
是可以躺平的
去当那种血牛之类的吧
现在有这种工作
就以前会听我爸说什么
他年轻没有钱的时候
曾经当过血牛
就是去参与人家什么药物实验
或是去什么捐血换钱
现在应该没有这种东西
但他那个看起来就是躺着
就可以工作
或许可以往这个方向去思考看看
然后你不是从韩国打工度假回来
我去韩国也遇不到你
下面一位
York
嘿嘿梦宫
以前没有买股票的时候
花钱如流水
但是开始投资股票的时候
随着资产翻倍成长
反而越来越省
因为总有种
今天省下来的一块钱
未来会变成两块
那想问梦宫有过一样的感受吗
这个就是我刚才前面讲的
就是当今天股票一直在上涨的时候
其实真的没有人
就是你在股票会做的人
会想要把钱拿出来花
因为你会觉得我的每一笔钱
现在都可以赚到更多钱
你甚至会非常的
反感任何要让你踩刹车的一个行为
据他来说在2020、2021
因为那时候我们有孩子
然后老婆说
那我们来买一间房好了
当时我是很不爽
我觉得这个盘这么好
怎么可以现在去买房子
然后那时候觉得说
嗯
其实后来看是一个
蛮不错的决定
你的心态会稍微的稳一点
因为你不是
所有的钱都在那种股票里面
你有些可能放到别的地方去
所以有时候赛翁司马
焉知非福
如果有一些必要的支出
就还是把它花下去吧
但是你这样的心态
是每个人都有
而且其实跟你的资产高低
没有关系
就是说你可能在
百万千万的时候
你有这个想法
那我告诉你
你破亿你十亿
你应该都还是会有一样的想法
因为我们身边的人
都有类似的想法
就是他们都会想要
有更多钱可以丢到市场里面
从来没有听过说什么
我这样赚够了
然后我就是
想要把所有钱都拿出来
我不要再参与市场
就是每个人都是不够的
甚至像之前有一个
身边的朋友跟我分享过
他在业界也算是待了蛮久
他说他只有看过一个
是真的赚到他的设定目标之后
然后就退休
把所有东西拿去买
就是拿去买债券
然后接着就是
领那个债券的利息
再也不碰股票
我说连0050都不买吗
都不买
就是直接完全的退出
其实很多人都讲过说
我到什么地方我就要退出
我就要陪家人
但他看下来就只有那一个人这样
那以我自己的角度来看
因为他算是比我资深的人
那我自己的角度是
我没有看过任何一个
就是有喊停的人
就基本上是停不下来
所以自己还是要去找到
一个平衡
特别是我还是在节目上
常常呼吁大家
要善待自己的家人
因为你在股票市场
你一天的震荡可能就是
你家人他跟你许愿
说要某个东西
你的震荡是远超过那个东西
然后你一直不想要买给他
但是不是每个人
都会一辈子在你身边陪着你
所以这个还是自己
要稍微小心一下
那下面一位
万事不绝对
孟公你好
我是马来西亚的听众
从EP300多开始到现在
你的好多无意间的话
都会让我好几次
shock的恍然大悟
非常感谢遇到这么好的节目
也谢谢你
祝你全家身体健康
开开心心
那我们希望这个
马来西亚的朋友
可以快乐健康平安
下面一位
dkdkdk93
孟公大好
上次留言没有念到
才说是不是要直上五万
不等人的
那这次直接修正一波QQ
我有个住在台北
从来没有开过
车的老同学
为了接送
可爱的女儿上幼稚园
人生第一台车
要直上宝马啦
哈哈
那祝福内湖数据长
行车平安
开车大吉
那我们希望他
千辛车快乐
那下面一位
愿常在念一下
宾美市
哦哦
孟公去搞好
Lisa和秋口
诺亚安哥好
听了五年第一次留言
过去曾经有很多
想说的话
真的要留言的时候
又不知道要从何说起
早期的我是完全听不懂
中间的气氛载
那最近开始懂产业而已
还是听不太懂
太细心了
我和孟公去搞同乡
孟公去搞说话时的尾音
常常会有客家腔
让人觉得好熟悉
早期孟公去搞
在0050还没有分拆时
停到006208相对便宜
当时的我有买
目前也翻一倍了
那我的工作忙碌
也很孤独
听节目好像变成
唯一的类社交活动
那至少没有和世界脱节
而且许多听众的留言
也都会给我生活中的思考
谢谢各位兄弟姐妹们
那最后希望孟公去搞
用客家话
对即将过生日的
我说那四个字
你还没给牌
谢谢
我为什么又要讲奇怪的话
就讲生日快乐
就讲生日快乐就好
为什么要乱接话
好啦
那前面讲的客家腔
其实我觉得
我客家腔没有很重
因为客家腔很好认
就是会说
哇
或是哪
那个东西好贵吧
太贵了哪
这个就是可能
客家人讲话会这样子
然后或是说
游子袋
我们不会讲睡袋
我们讲游子袋
然后或者说
一个人整天躺在那
就说
我整天在睡袋
所以
这个
你一听就知道
那我自己本身算是一半一半
就我妈妈是闽南人
花莲的闽南人
所以
可能是因为这样
有综合调
就是没有真的很客家
但是其实我们家族里面
蛮多人讲话
就是像我刚才前面讲的那样
然后有很多的客家腔
所以偶尔还是会不小心
这个露出一点客家腔
我觉得蛮有趣的
那下面有位
可以问问美国人
到底会不会做股票吗
其实现实上
不只是想问美国人
我想问台湾人
会不会做股票
像就像说
礼拜四的尾盘在那边拉
其实礼拜五有些东西
可以直接进攻
那确实有些东西有进攻
那只是后来就被灌回来
所以就代表说
现在已经是很多人
失去了勇气
那再来在
我刚才前面聊到说
11点12点的时候
其实有蛮多东西是
攻回去快要往平盘的方向走
我自己就跟着在那边狂敲
因为这个地方
其实真的可以去做一个
很漂亮的下影线去反攻
只是尾盘
有一堆人把它丢回来
我想说你们到底
会不会做股票
但现在讲的是这样子
如果下礼拜一
他妈在开DG往下走
我那个加码的
应该有把它丢出来
反正你们不要玩
老子也不要玩
我们要协助把这个盘砸掉
所以现在就是有一种
那种就是全面恐慌的感觉出来
我觉得比上一波修正
又再猛一点点
那我们再来观察会怎么样
下面一位
山中的大宝贝
孟公安
请问你可以用川普便秘的声音
宣布新竹周一台风假吗
也祝孟公宝贝股票
收到天上去
Constipated
没有办法
那就是希望新竹可以放假
因为我看到那个
好像是
就在新竹吧
有一个那个autobike
在公车旁边
直接变滑水道
虽然对啊
这不应该笑
可是那个影片
我重看了太多次
那个太经典了
就很危险啊
所以如果说
真的这个风雨达标的话
还是希望有关单位
要稍微体恤一下大家
以前我是非常反对台风假的人
那后来发现说
不能够这么自私
我自己很喜欢工作
没错
只是有些人他确实是
可能他家里出来
就会有危险或什么
我们要去在意一下这些人
所以我现在就站在
那个放假派
就尽量放
随便放没关系
反正我前面被那个
处置股关完之后
我现在对股票
也有新的认知了
我就想说
反正我就当成
我整天都被关也没有关系
好了那
下面一个太长跳过
这下面一位
pack
梦宫chika
自己可以用云霄飞车的emoji吗
好久没有在节目
听到有怪小的发言了
然后遇到下跌
反而会开始期待听QA
想知道梦宫会不会
有替在乎的人花钱
比花在自己身上
还甘愿的感觉
那虽然自己资产提高了
但觉得自己不值得
那最后希望梦宫可以用
猛男的语音包
祝我跟女友Peggy
保持愉快
一起变富一代
祝梦宫chika
一家平安健康又快乐爱您
我以前会很直接的跟你说
对没错
就是花在自己身上不值得
然后也不会花太多
但自从过去两个月的
这个疯狂红酒尝试之后
其实我是真的有点疯狂
所以我后来觉得说
我可能一次就花了好几年
应该可以花在自己身上的钱
但我的想法是跟你一模一样
就是我花在别人身上
是比较开心
不然说
像花在老婆身上
或是小孩身上
但如果是硬要选一个
花在小孩身上更夸张
就是你不会觉得这是一个问题
你买卡包给他
即便这个卡包
像有些卡包已经绝版了
像他很喜欢那个
好不要讲
因为讲的时候
一堆人在跑去买
就在更贵
他喜欢某一个绝版的卡包
然后我就会去买那个卡包给他
那个卡包其实算起来
比一般卡包贵
大概四五倍左右
可是当你看到他收到
然后在那边拆
然后还会自己跟你讲说
宝宝今天可以拆两个
我赶快洗澡
因为洗完澡可以拆两个
宝宝我今天表现好
可不可以再多拆一个什么的
你就一直想要
再买这个卡包给他
就即便你知道你是一个盘子
可是你就还是会
想要去让他开心这样
所以以前人家讲的什么
施比寿更有福
我得说我在二十几岁的时候
不知道这件事情
我也曾经想过说
为什么要生孩子脱油瓶
为什么要结婚
为什么要花这种钱
单身一辈子快乐一辈子
这个想法我都有过
但就是对
有些东西可能真的年纪一到才会懂
类似我们刚才前面讲的
后来发现说
我觉得人为什么越来越沉默
是因为你真的不需要
跟任何人讲太多
或试着去说服任何人
因为当你们是不同位阶
不同资产
不同的家庭背景
不同的家庭环境
不同的配置
你们真的是
有时候是没有办法对话的
那你现在跟人家讲
讲了半天也没有用
反正时间到了
他懂他就是会懂
那如果他不会懂
他一辈子跟你也没有交集
所以你真的有需要说服的
只有自己家庭最核心的人
就大概是这样子
但我完全认同你的说法
下面一位
GoodTone
GodTone
GodTone是什么
董神的ID是不是
MK大
我很好
大家好
好的
恭喜你很好
下面一位
其实我已经快没有很好
你知道吗
这样子一直跌下去
心中是不好受
最近不是在LINE上面
他有一个
可以回报大家状态的东西吗
我看到每个说自己不平安的
没有一个是风灾水灾
每个都是股票跌很惨
然后在那边靠摇
说什么家自己很惨
希望大家可以去救他
希望什么救援队
可以赶快到淹水的公园里面之类的
还是希望大家都
在这次的豪雨里面
可以平安健康
股票的事情
相较之家是小事
生命安全最重要
好像是
下面一位
SF985213
谢谢孟公去赶来每周分享
自己的生活跟市场的观点
我7月5号生日
可以跟我说那四个字吗
生日快乐
你看这样是不是皆大欢喜
下面一位
原住民的台语怎么念
孟公好
我是今年要考教征的考生
在教育职场发现
总有一些老师很混
但他们却是正式教师
而我努力的教学
却还只能够当个代理教师
心里满满的不平衡
但庆幸有时候努力的付出
总有回报
那有时候接住我情绪的
不是身边的好友
而是那些学生
倘若今年考上的话
我将分期捐出一个月的薪水
给流浪动物协会
或是抽出十组黑马卡
给地方男性
麻烦孟公帮我做决定
爱你
我是觉得
因为你后面那个抽奖
我要把你抽太麻烦了
你就直接捐给流浪动物协会
我觉得是蛮好的
然后再来讲前面那一段
我有一个unpopular opinion
但我认为应该蛮多人
会感同身受
你这样子一个
非常热血的想法
其实是好发语
就是因为你还没有
真的进入到
那个地方
所以你会觉得说
为什么有一堆
他妈的废物主管
失位速餐
不做事
然后他却可以是主管
为什么有那些人
他站着毛坑不拉屎
为什么有些医师
怎么看起来没有医德
为什么有些
什么做股票的
然后现在整天在
po干话
整天在喊救命
因为你还没有到
那个地方
就你到那个地方之后
有时候你会发现说
你可能本来是满腔热血
但是你被一些学生
或者说被一些学生家长
或是被很多的办公室
术物给磨掉了
所以你就会长得
像是比较圆融的样子
然后看在一些新来的人
就会觉得说
你很混混什么
但那已经是一个
就是为了生存
而长出来的样子
所以如果你今天到一个环境
你看到那些人
是长那个样子的话
你要思考的是
你想不想变成那个样子
因为你终究
你高几率会变成那个样子
你很难进去构造改革
然后让大家变成像你这种
满腔热血的样子
对我不想要帮
因为你看起来是一个新鲜人
好像帮你把未来
去盖上了一个
这个怎么讲
黑暗的阴影的感觉
可是社会
真的就是这样子运作的
就你还没有进去之前
你都会觉得说
里面的这些人
一堆站着毛坑不拉屎
可是你进去之后
你可能也变成是那样的人
当然我们还是希望
自己可以保有一些初心
还是希望有一些好事
可以发生
但后来对社会
就比较不会有这么多的批判
因为你开始渐渐的懂得
大概是这样
下面一位
Hikari
孟公我老公爱你
我是玛丽莎
我要祝竹南好友
闲亢利赚大钱
乖好爱大家
希望大家都赚大钱
下面一位
藤蛋蛋
孟公去搞我老公
这个就是应该是
股票底太多
开始有一些发病的人产生
下面一位
Andy5566
孟公去搞我
完全急助听你分享
和林口猛南门
在找有志人士
一起来林口发展
这是不是有力量之后
回馈社区的一种方式
也好奇想问孟公
当生意越大
也会伴随一些
复杂的关系吗
如果能够分享
再让小弟见面试面了
那最后想请孟公老大
用金牌讲师的语气
跟我的老师女友说
要放暑假了
姐妹们
又送走了
可爱的一届
辛苦你了
那也祝孟公一家平安健康
暑假也有更多的
美好回忆
那非常感谢这位兄弟
那前面讲的
事情是不是会变复杂
没错
所以其实我一向
都是跟大家说
特别是那些创业的人
有时候来QA问问题
我就说我自己的经验是
股东不要太复杂
因为股东复杂
事情就会变复杂
就会变麻烦
那所以绝大多数
像我自己参与的
一些生意都是
我可能就是里面
唯一一个股东
那我可能是出
超过七八成的钱
甚至是全资
但是我只拿十二十趴
这个是我家喜欢的一个模式
那可是我还是希望说
创办人自己也要
skin the game
就是你总是
自己头要洗下去
如果说你都是
在玩别人钱的话
我不能够期待
你一定会百分之百认真
你懂我意思吗
所以你没有多少钱
但是你愿意
整个头洗下去
这种人是我比较喜欢的
然后在林口目前
可能我们丢的东西
也是比较偏向说
我自己知道
这边可能需要这个东西
所以就会去做这样的投资
那时候会分享说
就是自己身边朋友
大家可能想说
这个东西可以搞看看的理由
是因为人家刚好提到了
这种事情的话
它不会是
可能像一些人想象的是
我们先去集资
然后弄一个fund
然后去投这些东西
这个可能
我不喜欢这样的模式
它比较偏向是
就像说真的有一些
屌的东西
你想要来林口做
或什么的
我可以吃下
我就直接全部自己吃了
也不是说什么
我不想分我朋友
或什么的
因为其实去投这种生意
对我们身边
这种做投资来讲
它的投报率
绝对都没有股票好了
所以其实每个人
想做这件事情
都是有点类似像你讲的
那种社会服务学习的态度
去做的
但我还是会希望
事情单纯一点
所以能够我全吃的
我一定是全吃
可是身边可能
有些朋友会发现说
这个东西我也有兴趣
你想要上车一点
OK那也让你上车一点
但大家的心态
应该比较偏向说
反正就是让这个创办人
去搞看看
看可不可以搞出
什么样的东西
所以其实我是
很不喜欢合伙生意
那自己目前可能
有搞到的
比较偏向是合伙生意的
会像是笑男这样
可是笑男
因为我自己就是过半的
所以大家连吵架
都不用吵架
因为你们没有人
投票投得赢我
那我就是去扛最大的风险
失败我也是去赔最多钱
所以大家都不有一见
那我会比较喜欢
这样的一个模式
就是我不喜欢说
当然大家会想说
应该都可以讨论
可以沟通
可是我的经验是
就是当今天人多
就是会嘴杂
所以最好的方式是
我当那个拿啤酒去你家的
你要投什么生意
你要做什么事情
我过去支持你
那笑男比较罕见一点
他算是我自己本身
是做妆的人
我其实是不希望
我希望越低调
然后躲起来越好
那只是因为刚好说
我们又找到一些
非常厉害的
业绩人士
可以去帮我run这个东西
所以我可以接受说
OK我在里面当一个
这个做妆的人
那当然目前上车的人
也都是自己的朋友
就他不会是那种
对外募资或什么
所以我觉得
就是事情一定要尽量的单纯
就是你尽量拿的钱
就是如果你是创办人
你就只拿少数几个人就好
你千万不要说什么
拿一堆人的钱
你要去迎合一堆人的期待
一堆人的想法
一堆人每个人
都要给你意见或什么的
你甚至会失去
你本来的一个初衷
或是你想要做的东西
这个就会比较可惜一点
那这可能跟大家一开始
听到的东西不太一样
一开始是人家跟我讲说
可以这样的做
所以我就直接分享出来
我觉得是一个蛮好的idea
就你要知道说
林口这边有蛮多人
他们是愿意去支持这样的东西
但实际下去做
应该理论上是
所有东西我能够吃
我就自己吃掉
那刚好身边朋友
假设你有不小心听到
你说你要上车
你也知道风险是什么
你要来你就可以来
这样子
可是不会是说什么
我要去揪人或什么
那个是我不喜欢的一个形式
好大家拜拜